bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 22
septembre merci vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'information tout de suite on commence
avec le sommaire de votre actualité
locale la ville des clayes-sous-bois
poursuit son projet de restructuration
du centre-ville
une réunion d'information vient de se
tenir autour de l'avenir de la halle du
marché et des écoles le projet ne fait
pas laminer l'unanimité auprès des
habitants l'établissement public du
château de versailles a lancé un appel
d'offres pour transformer trois de ses
bâtiments en hôtel explications à suivre
le président du parti chrétien démocrate
jean frédéric poisson se présente à la
primaire à droite
les raisons de cet engagement de
l'actuel et député des yvelines et nous
parlerons également des entreprises avec
muriel pringuet ce directrice des
opérations de la cgtm 78 qui a fait ses
portes ouvertes hier
bonsoir à vous nous nous reparlerons de
ce sujet dans quelques instants
et vous les avez peut-être aperçu
aujourd'hui ce midi une vingtaine de
cyclistes a fait une halte à magny les
hameaux il participe au tour alternatiba
partie de bayonne le 5 juin le tour a
fait escale dans 187 commune avec pour
objectif rallier paris le 26 septembre
et le festival de la capitale à chaque
étape les membres du collectif ont
multiplié conférences et rencontres avec
les citoyens pour parler du changement
climatique dans l'optique de la coop 21
la conférence internationale qui
débutera à paris le 30 novembre prochain
les précisions au micro de mélanie poker
dans micro dé mélanie poker nous on en
parle avec eux parce que jenson en sont
conscients pour leurs différents fait si
c'est possible il ya plein
d'alternatives concrètes possibles dès
aujourd'hui sur tous les domaines de la
vie quotidienne que ce soit
l'alimentation l'énergie des transports
la récupération etc
autre sujet maintenant aux
clayes-sous-bois les travaux
d'aménagement prévus font débat hier une
réunion publique d'information s'est
tenue sur le projet centre ville a dû
marcher et projet écoles centres de
loisirs
à l'espace philippe noiret une partie
des citoyens sont inquiets face à ces
projets déjà au mois de juillet ils
avaient manifesté leur mécontentement
ils ont recommencé hier
regardez le centre de loisirs des
bruyères les halles du marché
ces sujets préoccupent les clés sien
depuis plusieurs mois leur avenir est au
centre de discussions
la décision de déplacer le centre dans
une école de passe pas pour certains
d'entre eux ils étaient plus d'une
centaine à cette réunion publique
d'information où on est surtout là pour
le centre des bruyères et sa
réhabilitation et non pas sa fermeture
donc l'idée c'est de voir ce qu'elle va
proposer et aussi on peut encore
imaginer avoir une concertation avec
elle ce qu'ils nomment souhaitant est
encore possible parce qu'on lui dit ça
va nous coûter en impôts ça va nous
coûter 1 certes ça va nous coûter
mais quelle trace pas autre chose
qu'elle met des fonds cotés et on
réhabilite les bruyères pour les
habitants le centre des bruyères et le
poumon vert de la ville
pas question de l'abandonner mais la
décision est actée pour la mairie c'est
une question de budget cela permettrait
d'économiser environ 1,5 million d'euros
nous sommes confrontés à prendre des
décisions
ceux des responsables et nous allons
devoir donc faire des économies voire
peut-être même différer certains à
l'investissement nous ne fermons pas un
service mais nous allons accueillir les
enfants dans des bonnes conditions
autrement
la ville a fait déjà des gros efforts en
matière scolaire puisque nous avons mis
en place l'étape avec un budget de 500
mille euros par an nous avons
reconstruit une école élémentaire qui
avait brûlé on aurait pu ne pas la
reconstruire on a fait ce choix
et puis il s'agit et on pense aux six
mètres par accueillir les enfants dans
les centres de loisirs dans les
meilleures conditions
autre point de préoccupation les halles
du marché elles seront déconstruits
depuis déménagé en face de leur
emplacement actuel
coût du projet environ 2 millions
d'euros des sujets largement discuté
pendant cette réunion publique où le
mécontentement s'est fait entendre
la mairie ne reviendra pas sur ses
décisions un appel à projets concernant
les halles doit être lancé dans les
prochaines semaines et une autre
information politique la tête de liste
du fn aux régionales en ile-de-france le
trésorier du front
canal va les rangs de saint-just a été
mise en examen ce lundi pour recel
d'abus de biens sociaux dans la sphère
du financement du parti
il a été placé sous le statut de témoin
assisté pour le délit de complicité
d'escroquerie au préjudice de l'état
lors des législatives de 2012 contacté
par l'afp ewa les rangs de saint-just a
protesté contre sa mise en examen
soulignant qu'il avait antennes et qu'il
avait été entendu sur les mêmes faits en
juin et maintenant un mot de patrimoine
dormir au château de versailles ce sera
peut-être un jour envisageable
l'établissement public du château a
lancé un appel d'offres pour transformer
trois de ses bâtiments en hôtel il a
reçu une vingtaine de candidatures
françaises et étrangères
le groupe accor semblent montrer un
intérêt certain pour le projet et se
serait même porté acquéreur sephora
namani nous en dit plus faute de moyens
pour assurer la restauration le château
de versailles vient de lancer un appel
d'offres pour un contrat de concession
des bâtiments du grand et petit contrôle
et du pavillon des 100 marches l'état de
délabrement de ses bâtiments proches de
l'orangerie explique l'initiative de
l'établissement public du château
vingt candidats ont répondu à l'appel et
soumis un projet dans l'espoir de
décrocher cette concession pour une
durée de 50 ans le groupe hôtel et
patrimoine développe des hôtels dans les
bâtiments historiques et fait partie des
postulants leur souhaite créer un hôtel
de charme 5 étoiles d'une trentaine de
chambres exclusive notre adn aux
caractéristiques à nous c'est un très
grand respect de la partie historique et
développer une offre commerciale
raisonnable
on est vraiment appliquée après avez
l'esprit des lieux l'esprit du lieu dans
lequel on travaille pour nous versailles
s'est imposé comme naturelle le député
maire de versailles françois de mazières
approuve ce projet le château ne pouvant
assurer lui même la restauration
certains détracteurs se font néanmoins
entendre il préfère avoir à l'intérieur
du bâtiment la construction d'un musée
louis xiv accompagné d'expositions
temporaires pour financer la
restauration du site
c'est un hôtel de luxe qui est contraire
à l'image de charme france
c'est ça va attirer des milliardaires
éloigné de la ville et de l'intérêt pour
la ville
ça c'est la première chose ça nuit au
modèle français et ça va dans le sens de
l'aseptisation de la standardisation 2
ça ne rapportera rien c'est à dire cinq
cent mille euros par an c'est de la
rigolade
puisque ce parti il rapporte 3 millions
par an par le château le château de
versailles n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer
sur le sujet le nom de la société
retenue sera dévoilée en janvier 2016 et
la ville de versailles organise pour la
sixième année consécutive la deuxième
fois cette année une vente aux enchères
publiques du matériel dont elle veut se
séparer
alors il s'agit principalement de biens
informatiques de mobilier il ya
également des véhicules
la vente se déroule sur le site
www.whotels.com jusqu'au 1er octobre 10h
si vous voulez plus de renseignements
n'hésitez pas à aller sur le site vente
aux enchères @ versailles pour faire
pardon excusez moi c'est un mail
n'hésitez pas envoyez un mail à cette
adresse et nous recevons en plateau
muriel pringuez bonsoir vous êtes je le
rappelle la directrice des opérations de
la cgem cgpme 78 la confédération des
petites et moyennes entreprises dans les
yvelines
hier vous avez organiser vos portes
ouvertes à rambouillet quels ont été les
interrogations les deux mondes nouveaux
adhérents et était-il nombreux oui nous
avons eu le plaisir de recevoir plus de
150 personnes en une journée ce qui est
déjà pas mal vu le nombre d'adhérents
que nous avons puisque nous sommes 650
dans les yvelines ce qui permet déjà de
représenter un certain nombre
d'entreprises
ça nous a permis même entre nous pouvoir
nous retrouver une fois de plus c'est
pouvoir échanger sur nos préoccupations
et surtout de pouvoir faire adhérer déjà
plus d'une vingtaine de personnes et de
chefs d'entreprise d'hier de petites et
moyennes entreprises pouvant aller
jusqu'à 300 personnes et de pouvoir
discuter de nos préoccupations actuelles
qui sont effectivement la simplification
du système qu'on demande toujours et le
fait de tenir les promesses qui avaient
été faites alors justement pour les
téléspectateurs qui ne sont pas très au
point qu'on connaissait peut-être pas ce
monde des des entreprises des petites
entreprises des artisans
voilà le méliès implication du la
simplification du système qu'est ce que
à quoi cela correspond justement pour
ces entreprises alors c'est tout
simplement de pouvoir remplir - de
documents d'éviter d'avoir à tout
refaire
la bonne croix dans la bonne case ce qui
fait qu'on peut gagner un temps énorme
et du coup plutôt passé ce temps à
remplir le carnet de commandes et
surtout à pouvoir créer les embauches ce
qui je pense aujourd'hui est la
préoccupation de toutes les entreprises
mais aussi de tous les salariés
est-ce que l'apprentissage a aussi été
au coeur de vos discussions hier
oui tout à fait puisque aujourd'hui de
plus en plus le nombre d'apprentis
finalement diminue faute de moyens qu'on
nous annonce un tiers de contrat en
moins ce qui veut dire même pour les
entreprises qui souhaitent aider les
jeunes à trouver un véritable métier en
les accompagnant il ya moins de
possibilité de pouvoir entre eux en
trouver quelle que soit l'entreprise
quand on discute et même avec le trianon
palace puisqu'on parlait de versailles
la semaine dernière l'allègement
salariale est aussi au coeur des masaï
était aussi au coeur de vos
préoccupations en cette rentrée
oui puisque il y avait une promesse de
fait par rapport à janvier sur le fait
qu'ils aient une baisse déjà salariale
ce qui peut permettre aux entreprises de
pouvoir finalement embaucher plus aussi
tout simplement
derrière cette belle ça a été reporté au
mois d'avril
est ce que ce sera au mois d'avril où
est-ce qu'à ce moment là il y aura un
nouveau de priorité que ce sera encore
reporté c'est notre grande préoccupation
aujourd'hui on a juste envie de dire si
vous pouvez pas le premier et ne le fait
pas mais on n'est pas des chasseurs de
primes dites nous simplement ce qui peut
être réellement fait le climat en début
d'année est un peu morose qu'est ce
qu'ils attendent vraiment on attend d'un
petit coup de pouce du de la part du
gouvernement
les entreprises attendent ça alors coup
de pouce pas véritablement on sait
simplement de les aider dans leur
travail au quotidien surtout à travers
cette simplification et quand ils leur
promettent des choses c'est tout
simplement de les tenir pour qu'on
puisse s'appuyer dessus est
véritablement avancer le gouvernement
vient d'annoncer les mercredis à 16
septembre l'harmonisation des dates de
déclaration de tva et d'impôt sur les
sociétés est ce que c'est un effort
suffisant pour vous pour ma part non pas
vraiment parce que ça veut dire que
j'avais prévu une journée si je prends
le rôle de chef d'entreprise de pouvoir
étaler ça dans mon travail mais
maintenant ça va au contraire augmenté
la charge de travail sur la même période
ce qui veut dire que sur cette période
là on pourra pas se focaliser sur nos
salariés et sur nos clients une fois
plus quelles sont les demandes concrètes
voilà pour expliquer convaincre nos
hôtes et scripteur que les entreprises
les artisans formule pour l'angola va
essayer d'arrêter de sortir une des
modifications du code de travail toutes
les semaines justement les règles de
travail va être
ça pour repenser qu'est ce que vous
apportez qu'est ce que vous attendez
justement de ça alors tout simplement un
allègement puisque si on regarde je
pense qu'on a repris le nom de pages on
a plus d'une centaine de pages qui ont
été publiés cet été je pense qu'il ya
aucun chef d'entreprise qui a eu le
temps de lire ces centaines de pages
parce que même quand on est dedans c'est
pas très évident donc si on pouvait les
réduire
ça veut pas dire diminuées tous les tous
les bénéfices et avantages qui sont donc
si simplement les simplifier de manière
à ce que ce soit plus clair et pour les
salariés et pour les entreprises et
qu'on puisse embaucher plus facilement
parce que plus c'est compliqué - en
bouche parce que souvent ce sont des
entreprises parfois il ya que un salarié
le seriez aussi le patron ou deux donc
c'est vraiment très compliqué de se
mettre à jour au niveau du code de
travail des textes de voix pour
justement tout savoir c'est bien ça
alors même déjà quand on a un salarié
effectivement dans les entreprises mais
aujourd'hui on a même des entrepreneurs
qui sont plusieurs centaines
je peux vous assurer que vous ayez un
scénario plusieurs centaines
c'est toujours la même difficulté de
pouvoir interpréter tous ces textes est
d'arriver à les mettre en place surtout
quand il roule un contrôle hier près de
deux mille artisans et commerçants ont
défilé dans les rues de paris pour
dénoncer les dysfonctionnements du
régime social des indépendants auxquels
ils sont affiliés
la cgpme donc a appelé les
parlementaires à constituer une union
sacrée pour décider de mesures d'urgence
face à ce dysfonctionnement
c'est votre cheval de bataille
l'aération cette rentrée oui c'est alors
là c'est un double cheval de bataille
parce qu'effectivement il est temps de
pouvoir faciliter aux sept partis là
tout simplement des entreprises qui sont
hélas obligé de deux filles de jaillir
de finir leur vie entre guillemets de
déposer le bilan
on y arrive même pas les entreprises qui
souhaite le développer n'arrive même pas
à savoir à qui s'adresser
hier justement à la page journée portes
ouvertes on est le plaisir d'avoir un
représentant du rsiq était parmi nous
qui a pu répondre directement aux
questions des chefs d'entreprise et
résoudre leur dossier en direct etc des
mois finalement d'efforts des uns et des
autres qui ont été finalement gérer en
une journée donc se mettre autour d'une
table c'est pour nous la meilleure
solution
est-ce que vous avez un cas concret de
quel poids dont parlait justement de ces
récits car il ya vraiment des choses qui
se passent ils sont un petit peu
incroyable par rapport justement à ce
régime social des indépendants
mais la grande difficulté que vous avez
c'est que quand vous devez faire vos
déclarations et surtout savoir même vers
qui vous adressez derrière pour pouvoir
vous former en tant que chef
d'entreprise parce que même eux doivent
se former
effectivement ça devient difficile parce
que on sait pas vraiment
si vous êtes affilié ainsi vous êtes
affilié à l'autre si vous avez une
question sur votre tête sur vos charges
sur une problématique de santé oms qui
va vous répondre comment là aujourd'hui
c'est la grande question et vous pouvez
passer des semaines sans toujours avoir
de réponse donc finalement vraiment
celle administratif qui pèse justement
sur nos entreprises nos petites
entreprises en ce moment oui si on
pouvait consacrer ce temps
administratifs à remplir les carnets de
commandes et donc à pouvoir embaucher je
pense que tout montrait plus content
pour quelles actions mettez-vous en
place justement au sein de l'ag cgpme66
un entrepreneur un artisan souhaite vous
rejoindre qu'est ce que vous mettez en
place pour justement les aider alors les
prochaines actions mais il va et toi y
avoir un appui business dans une semaine
où on propose à nos adhérents de venir
simplement parler d'eux pendant deux
minutes mais également parler de ce
qu'ils attendent de ce qu'ils peuvent
avoir besoin de manière à pouvoir
échanger plus facilement entre eux mais
également des formations sur la gestion
des compétences des formations sur
justement les documents uniques les
obligations des chefs d'entreprise par
exemple la déclaration sociale qui vote
obligatoire mensuellement à partir de
janvier
comment les aider pour faciliter leur
quotidien dans les mois à venir donc ce
sont des conseils pratiques mais aussi
parfois un moyen de rompre l'isolément
de ces chefs d'entreprise qui est
parfois se retrouve assez seul oui alors
là je le prends ma casquette de chef
d'entreprise effectivement on a
l'impression toujours à la tête dans le
guidon
là c'est la montage de pouvoir se poser
un peu se rende compte qu'on est
plusieurs à avoir les mêmes problèmes et
par conséquent pouvoir échanger sur
justement des bonnes pratiques pour
trouver des solutions et pour avancer
une dernière question à muret le
pringuez une manifestation avait été
organisée en décembre l'année dernière
les patrons justement avait appris les
bons endroits étaient descendus dans les
rues de paris pour manifester est ce qu
une autre action de ce type
peut-elle être envisagée prochainement
alors oui effectivement j'avais plaisir
de faire partie de ces milliers patrons
qui étaient dans la rue derrière
genevieve bell que qu'on peut voir à
l'écran banos présidente du 78 alors
autres actions pour l'instant pour le
rien de prévu à ma connaissance mais je
pense que si effectivement ça n'avance
pas elle les patrons sont prêts à
redescendre dans la rue pour exprimer
leur mécontentement et bien merci à
beaucoup à muret frei est d'avoir
répondu à notre question si vous étiez
plus de renseignements n'hésitez pas à
aller sur le site internet donc
www.gg.ca 118 point fr c'est bien ça
cgpme 70
très bien merci mais pas un mot de
l'enseignement supérieur justement la
rentrée et on court encore pour certains
de ces étudiants attrape un sivu
supérieur de l'environnement dans le
parc d'activités de pi salou a formé
depuis 1993 plus de 700 étudiants aux
métiers touchant à l'environnement et au
développement durable
mélanie poquet a suivi le premier jour
au sein de l'établissement
parmi ces étudiants se trouvent deux
futurs ingénieurs juristes des
responsables développement durable ou
encore des responsables d'hygiène
qualité sécurité environnement
alors moi j'aimerais m'orienter dans le
domaine de l'eau donc que ce soit
l'hydraulique fluviale ou l'hydraulique
urbaine l'eau potable etc à shenyang et
c'est dans cette optique là deux blessés
dans l'environnement
je me voyais plus écologue mais au fil
des années justement liesse nous a
permis de nous ouvrir à différentes
thématiques de l'environnement et à ne
trouve à trouver une autre voie
dans ce domaine là donc moi je suis
devenu maintenant fin je sais leur être
imputés à devenir auditeurs cette
rentrée à l'institut supérieur de
l'environnement attrape marque aussi du
changement à la tête de l'établissement
avec notamment l'arrivée d'argent de
coussergues ancien gérant de
portefeuille d'une société française
c'est des métiers qui sont maintenant
plus très impliqué dans toutes les
entreprises c'est-à-dire que l'on
prépare les étudiants aussi pour secteur
l'environnement mais aussi maintenant
des étudiants qui entrait dans toutes
les entreprises sur les questions
environnementales et ça c'est
extrêmement porteur et c'est ce qui
attirait toutes leurs dimensions où
chaque année une trentaine d'étudiants
sortent diplômés dès cette rentrée ils
ont un point de mire et pas des moindres
être acteur de la coop 21 la conférence
sur le climat qui débute à paris le 30
novembre prochain et nous sommes mariés
comme chaque semaine nous parlerons
poétique avec wilfrid bonsoir à vous on
laisse de côté les régionales pour
s'intéresser à la présidentielle dès
maintenant
bonsoir florame la présidentielle c'est
vrai c'est encore loin c'est 2017 mais
déjà chacun se positionne est le mot qui
revient le plus souvent en ce moment
elle c'est le mot primaire ce vote avant
l'heure qui permet un camp de désigner
son candidat à gauche on avait lancé ce
dispositif en 2011 c'était une primaire
ouverte à tous les électeurs pas
uniquement aux adhérents socialistes ou
des autres formations de gauche
à près de 3 millions de personnes
s'étaient ainsi déplacé aux yeux en
avait fait le choix de françois hollande
devant martine aubry
rien ne dit qu'à gauche on renouvelle
cette expérience on y
jean mal françois hollande s'il est
candidat à sa propre succession se
mettre en concurrence avec les autres
ténors du ps
du coup certains commencent à exercer
une certaine pression benoît hamon
député des yvelines par exemple annoncé
et qu'il aimerait bien être candidats à
une primaire c'est donc à droite que les
choses s'accélèrent
c'est ce mardi soir que nicolas sarkozy
président des républicains doit annoncer
la nomination de la haute autorité
chargée de contrôler le bon déroulement
des primaires et de leurs organisations
la primaire pour la droite se déroulera
le 20 et le 27 novembre 2016 si
nécessaire quelques noms alain juppé
françois fillon xavier bertrand nadine
morano christian estrosi uniquement si
nicolas sarkozy ne se présente pas c est
lui-même qu'il l'a précisé
et puis depuis la fin de la semaine
dernière jean frédéric poisson le
président du parti chrétien-démocrate
adhérent à l'ump député des yvelines
il s'est déclaré dans les colonnes de
valeurs actuelles tout simplement car il
me se retrouve dans aucun à des autres
candidats et il le dit très clairement
puisqu'on lui a posé la question écouter
ils sont engagés dans une espèce de
guerre de chefs que nos sympathisants
d'abord mais au-delà l'ensemble des
français de ne même pas n'apprécie pas
non plus passer ce qu'ils me disent tous
les jours deuxièmement je trouve que les
projets qui sont défendues aujourd'hui
sont sur une ligne qui est très très
libéral est beaucoup trop à mon goût et
ça n'est pas la philosophie du parti
démocrate que je représente pour cette
élection ce n'est pas non plus je crois
le besoin les besoins du pays qui
réclament cercle de la liberté mais
également du partage de la générosité de
l'ouverture
et troisièmement je constate également
que la perte de crédit dont souffrent
les candidats qui sont aujourd'hui
déclaré qui est dû au fait que
finalement ils ont beaucoup participé
aux affaires en aidant d'après mandature
précédente et bien ne leur permet pas
aujourd'hui à mon avis de solliciter
tranquillement la confiance des français
jean frédéric poisson c'est ce proche de
christine boutin et lui a d'ailleurs
succédé à la tête du parti
chrétien-démocrate député des yvelines
sur le secteur de rambouillet il a
surtout fait parler de lui en mobilisant
contre le mariage pour tous et
maintenant il va devoir dépasser à aller
au delà de cette image j'ai travaillé
depuis huit ans maintenant dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée nationale
france sur des sujets extrêmement divers
je suis très investi sur tout ce qui
touche aux conditions de travail et la
santé au travail vos relations de social
dans l'entreprise j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur d'autres questions de
société les questions de toxicomanies
je travaille beaucoup sur le pouvoir
d'achat des familles sur les
institutions sur les collectivités et
maintenant le moment est venu de faire
fructifier de présenter aux français
tout ce travail que j'ai accompli dans
une certaine forme de discrétion c'est
vrai à l'assemblée nationale jean
frédéric poisson est outsider dans cette
primaire mais il occupe le terrain il
est régulièrement invité dans les médias
nationaux il évoquait encore ce matin
sur rmc le suicide assisté en rappelant
que la justice devait rappeler
l'interdiction de tuer et puis en
juillet à coup d'éclat il était en syrie
partir en contre et sur sa propre
initiative bachar al assad et à droite
que pense-t-on de cette candidature
alors c'est le président du sénat gérard
larcher qui le connaît bien pour les
avoir confiées par le passé la tête de
la mairie de rambouillet qui nous attend
il est légitime que monsieur poisson
puisse se présenter à l'élection
primaire pour les familles du centre et
de la droite
moi même je suis un peu le sage la
commission d'organisation de ces
primaires
je souhaite que les choses s'y passent
bien loyalement qu'il y ait un maximum
de votants de ceux qui se reconnaissent
je parle pas de militants politiques de
citoyens dans les familles du centre et
de la droite des gaullistes et puis le
candidat qui sera choisi
ça deviendra le corps d'huile à tous et
je l'espère il sera le président de la
république
la guerre de la primaire se poursuit à
droite verdict donc fin à 2016 attention
tout de même c'est un exercice risqué
après la campagne il faudra se rallier
derrière le vainqueur gare donc à ne pas
frapper trop fort pendant la campagne
merci wilfried est justement jean
frédéric poisson et gérard larcher que
nous retrouvons sceptiques excusez moi à
vos côtés très bien merci beaucoup
wilfried initiatives solidaires à
présent ce week-end se tenait à huis en
cours la fois à la brocante cette année
des stands étaient tenus par le conseil
municipal des enfants après avoir
collecté des vêtements et des livres
dans divers établissements scolaires de
la commune
il les vendait au profit d'une
association ils ont récolté 578 euros et
ont atteint leur objectif
écoutez élise le mot au micro de michael
almy d'euros l'argent qu'on va recevoir
il va être rendus à l'association les
blouses roses pour qu'il donne des
choses pour les enfants malades pour ça
alors l'envi début de l'année dernière
donc il ya eu plusieurs groupes et on en
a fait quelques-uns donc nous n'aimons
de sécurité routière et dans sa barre on
a un projet dont cas pour aider les
enfants malades et un mot de santé à
présent la lmp la mutuelle des ménages
prévoyant fêté jeudi dernier à
versailles c'est 160 ans d'existence
cette mutuelle créée en 1854 compte
aujourd'hui plus de 50 mille adhérents
précurseur à l'époque cet outil de
solidarité s'est peu à peu ouverts à
toutes les couches sociales pour devenir
la mutuelle d'aujourd'hui
regardez ce reportage réalisé par
william el est david charpentier les
ménages prévoyant une mutuelle qui
perdure créée en 1854 par le baron
caruhel de saint martin la lmp fêté
jeudi dernier à versailles c'est cent
soixante années d'existence aux origines
la lmp permettait à ses sociétaires de
bénéficier d'un accès gratuit aux soins
puis elle s'est développée en accord
avec l'évolution des besoins sociaux se
soigner
d'avoir des médicaments de cette classe
n'était pas si évident que ça et puis
surtout première mutuelle à accepter les
femmes comme sociétaire la lmp signe en
1955 un contrat d'entreprise avec le
site renault de flins une stratégie qui
lui permettra de passer de 1000
sociétaires en 1945 à plus de 60
millions dans les années 2000 répondre à
la norme solvabilité ii européenne qui
va nous imposer de la stabilité
supplémentaire
donc c'est vraiment un grand défi à
relever parce que 1er janvier 2016
offrant soumis aux mêmes règles que les
grand reporter au 1er janvier 2016 la
réforme européenne de solvabilité 2 et
surtout un défi pour les petites
mutuelles au vu des frais de gestion
importants qui seront engendrées le
début d'une nouvelle ère pour les
assureurs et c'est bientôt la fin de
cette édition mais avant de nous quitter
je propose de parler de sport un mot de
golf à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines a organisé ce
week-end la quatrième édition de son
wave festival d activité gratuite était
organisée de 14h à minuit dans toute la
structure
objectif de ce rendez vous faire
découvrir ce sport aux débutants les
novices ont pu s'essayer au footing
c'est-à-dire au jeu court ou encore au
prat au practice de jour et de nuit
enrique eu pour télécharger de projets
avec casque et vous présente cette
journée golfique
on a pu organiser ses visites sur ce
site qui a une histoire plutôt
exceptionnel depuis louis xiv et avec
une évolution jusqu'à la ryder cup 2018
et puis potentiellement les jeux
olympiques de 2024
il ya beaucoup de familles du coup c'est
intéressant parce que les familles
découvrent qu'ils peuvent jouer à la
fois les adultes avec les enfants ils
peuvent jouer ensemble sur le parcours
ils peuvent leur ensemble au practice
il ya des débutants effectivement et
mais en fait on y lit à tout le monde
quoi il ya famille golfeurs des copains
voilà c'est vraiment pour tous et c'est
la fin de cette édition merci de nous
avoir suivis tout de suite restez avec
nous vous avez rendez vous avec
nouradine haguenau pour le 7-8 société
pour ma part je retrouve dès demain à 18
heures pour une nouvelle et
du journal en direct je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée sur tv fil 78